avec les au Niger au Gabon cet été
votre politique néocoloniale et
impérialiste en Afrique a connu l'un des
plus grands revers la faute à une
politique pilotée pour nos intérêts
économiques de l'uranium au pétrole de
même ce même fait colonial qui est
dénoncé dans nos outre-mer qui vivent la
persistance de cette mentalité dans des
territoires exploités uniquement pour
leurs ressources naturelles sans égard
pour la souffrance des populations au
risque d'une explosion sociale que vous
ne saurez pas avoir venir au Sahel vous
avez demandé aux militaires de faire de
l'humanitaire aux humanitaires vous leur
avez demandé de faire de la politique au
diplomates vous leur avez demandé de
n'être que la caisse de résonance de
l'Élysée et donc des multinationales
françaises et quand vous prétendez
défendre la démocratie les peuples vous
répondent en dénonçant et en rejetant
les tricheurs il n'y a pas de sentiment
anti-français les peuples africains sont
anti-politiques françaises ils veulent
accéder à leur deuxième indépendance
celle de la souveraineté économique et
financière nous devrions
nous devrions fermer les bases
militaires en Afrique et en finir avec
le français et que dire du franc
pacifique au lieu de cela vous continuez
à exiger des sanctions internationales
qui étouffent les peuples et renforcent
l'image d'une politique française
aveugle aux besoins des peuples vous
avez même exigé la fin de la coopération
culturelle avec tous les artistes
maliens burkinabe et nigérien est
bloquer l'obtention des visas pour les
étudiants ressortissants de ces états en
appliquant ces injustes sanctions
collectives vous vous en prenez aux
puissants vecteurs de paix que sont les
coopérations culturelles et
intellectuelles madame Colonna et
Monsieur Vigier quand l'arrogance
néocoloniale va-t-elle quitter nos
politiques publiques
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Député le coq il m'arrive
d'être d'accord avec vous j'espère que
personne ne s'en offusque mais là je ne
saurais l'être tant vos propos dépassent
la réalité
au Gabon comme au Niger notre politique
et guidé par les deux principes qui nous
gouvernent toujours 1 nous condamnons
tous les coups d'État
2 nous soutenons les organisations
régionales au Niger la CEDEAO au Gabon
les pays d'Afrique centrale voilà la
réalité et je voudrais aussi vous
rappeler que l'Afrique ne se réduit pas
au Sahel et à quelques jantes qui
remettent en cause la France pour
masquer leur propre échecs ne faites pas
comme Monsieur le Député je vous en prie
bien au contraire les relations entre la
France et la plupart des 54 pays
africains se portent bien ce porte même
très bien en 15 ans le volume de nos
investissements a doublé est en fait nos
universités sont attractives elles
accueillent aujourd'hui 92
000 étudiants africains soit 40% de plus
qu'en 2017 c'est un fait nous avons
augmenté nos traits de développement de
50% en 6 ans c'est un fait partout sur
le continent nous menons des
coopérations avec les scientifiques les
jeunesses les sportifs
les artistes monsieur le députés et à
propos des artistes permettez-moi de
dire que les mesures que vous évoquez
non jamais ni été prise ni même n'ont
été demandé
et surtout nous traitons l'Afrique
sur un pied d'égalité pour traiter avec
elle les grands défis de demain les
grands enjeux que sont la fin le
développement le climat la santé
mondiale nous soutenons dans la
gouvernance mondiale le poids de
l'Afrique et des pays africains nous le
faisons au G20 nous le faisons conseils
de sécurité l'Union africaine vient
d'entrer au G20 avec notre soutien voilà
la réalité monsieur députés et voilà ce
que nous faisons avec nos partenaires
africains je vous remercie je vous
remercie madame la ministre monsieur
Lecoq merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre entendait ce que disent les
peuples africains entendaient les
evidemment c'est pas toute l'Afrique les
deux minutes qui me sont accordés ne me
permettent pas de vous faire la liste
mais vous savez très bien que la partie
CDAO par exemple et bien Lancy les
anciennes colonies françaises ont un
message à donner à la France et ce
message vous avez du mal à l'entendre et
c'était le sens de cette question je
merci monsieur le député